قبل أن نصل إلى ذلك، جيم، مجرد بعض
الأخبار العاجلة، لقد أكدنا للتو مع
متحدث عسكري إسرائيلي أنهم
استعادوا خمس جثث
لرهائن ذكور، ثلاثة منهم عسكريون واثنان
منهم مدنيون، ونعلم أنه تم
العثور عليهم في مخيم جباليا للاجئين.
في شمال غزة الآن لا نعرف
هويات هؤلاء الرهائن حتى
الآن أه لكننا بالطبع سنستمر في
الحصول على مزيد من المعلومات حول ذلك مجرد
تطور مؤسف آخر ولكن
هناك تطورات كبيرة على
الجنوب في جنوب غزة عند معبر رفح
مع مصر  ألقوا نظرة على ما
حدث قبل بضع ساعات فقط
[تصفيق] [
موسيقى]
فوضى مطلقة في الشوارع عند
ذلك المعبر الحيوي حيث تأتي شاحنات المساعدات
من مصر إلى غزة،
يبدو أن الحشود يائسة للغاية في محاولة الاستيلاء على
أي مساعدات يمكنهم الحصول عليها منها
الشاحنات في وضع يعاني فيه
جميع سكان غزة من
انعدام الأمن الغذائي الحاد، ومستوى كارثي من
الناس الذين ليس لديهم ما يكفي ليأكلوا، واليأس، والغضب، والغضب المتزايد، الذي
أصبح الناس غاضبين للغاية لدرجة أنهم
كانوا يحاولون الهروب من  شاحنات
تحمل كل ما في
أيديها، لا نعرف كيف اندلع إطلاق النار
أو من أطلق
النار بالضبط، ولا نعرف ما إذا كان أي شخص قد أصيب
أو قُتل، ولكن من الواضح ما إذا كان هذا الفيديو
لا يسلط الضوء على مدى يأس
الوضع  موجود داخل غزة الآن،
كل ما عليك فعله هو النظر والاستماع إلى
جيم، حسنًا، دعنا نعود إلى ذلك،
أعلم أنه ليس هناك الكثير مما يمكنك
إخبارنا به ولكن عندما ننظر إلى هذا
الفيديو وإذا كان بإمكاننا عرضه مرة أخرى
مشاهدينا، إنها
رؤية جوية من الأعلى لما يبدو وكأنه
فوضى في هذا الحشد، هل هذا هو المكان الذي
حدثت فيه الطلقات النارية أم أعني
أنه يبدو وكأن الناس يحملون المساعدات على
أكتافهم وعلى ظهورهم بعيدًا
عن شاحنات المساعدات.  أحاول فقط أن
أفهم ما إذا كنا نعرف ما إذا كان إطلاق النار
قد انطلق بسبب الاندفاع
للحصول على تلك الإمدادات أم أن هذا القتال
كان يدور بالقرب من مكان الحادث؟
أعتقد أننا لا نملك جميع الإجابات
ومع ذلك، هذا صحيح تمامًا يا جيم، فالوضع
فوضوي للغاية هناك الآن، وكل
ما يمكننا القيام به وكل ما يمكننا التأكد منه من
هذا الفيديو هو أنه كانت هناك
حشود ضخمة هرعت بشكل أساسي إلى
قافلة شاحنات المساعدات بمجرد
وصولها عبر معبر رفح.  من
مصر، كان الناس يحاولون اقتحام
الشاحنات، وكانوا يحاولون سرقة
أشياء من الشاحنات، ولدينا
مقاطع فيديو أخرى حيث ترى أشخاصًا يحملون
مجموعات من العناصر في أيديهم،
وربما لا يعرفون بالضبط ما الذي
كانوا يستولون عليه، لكنهم استولوا على ما
تمكنوا من ذلك فهربوا، ثم في
مرحلة ما تم إطلاق النار وسمع الكثير من إطلاق
النار، لا نعرف من
أطلق النار، لا نعرف
من أين جاء إطلاق النار، كلها
أسئلة لا تزال بدون إجابة، لكنها في الحقيقة
لا يسلط الضوء على مدى تقلب
الوضع داخل غزة في الوقت الحالي يا
جيم